bonjour à toutes et à tous oui vous avez
lu le titre de cette vidéo
les poissons eux aussi ont des chagrins
d'amour
donc vous avez le temps du jingle pour
imaginer comment les chercheurs ont pu
arriver à une telle conclusion qui
étudia les émotions des poissons et
discuter de leurs peines de coeur on va
pas se mentir c'est pas facile
nathan mais comment ça va te quitter aux
2,9 qu'est ce que tu as fait pour
étudier les chagrins d'amour chez les
poissons une chercheuse de dijon a
imaginé une expérience qui permet de
connaître l'état émotionnel dans lequel
se trouvent les poissons sans avoir à
récolter leurs témoignages
l'équipe de recherche s'est intéressé
aux cichlidés zébré un petit poisson
tropical
l'idée est de placer ces poissons devant
une situation ambiguë et d'observer la
réaction
c'est un peu comme si je vous plaçait
devant ce ver qui est un art est le
meilleur et rennes meilleure which quoi
l'état et que je vous demandais s'il est
à moitié vide ou à moitié plein en
fonction de votre réponse qui sera
optimiste ou pessimiste on saura si vous
n'y trouvez dans un état émotionnel
plutôt positif ou négatif
les chercheurs ont commencé par
entraîner leur sit in et à ouvrir une
boîte qui possède un couvercle ils sont
habitués les poissons à la présence de
cet objet et ont suscité leur intérêt en
y cachant une friandise
petit à petit les poissons sont devenus
de plus en plus doués pour ouvrir les
boîtes
cet exercice est coûteux pour le poisson
c'est fatigant et ils s'exposent aux
potentiels prédateurs qui pourrait être
dans son environnement
donc il faut que la récompense vaille le
coup
dans le cas des cichlidés c'est un petit
verre n'est menée mien c'est un peu
leurs chips a plu les chercheurs ont
ensuite entraîné les cichlidés à
distinguer les boîtes qui contiennent de
la nourriture de celles qui n'en
contiennent pas la boîte au couvercle
noir posé à gauche contient des
friandises
alors que la boîte au couvercle blanc
posé à droite n'en contient pas
au bout de quelques jours d'entraînement
les poissons ne vont ouvrir que les
boîtes qui l'ont identifié comme
contenant des friandises et s'ils se
déplacent pour ouvrir des boîtes ne
contenant pas de friandises
c'est au bout dans l'ombre évidemment
les chercheurs ont aussi entraîné des
cichlidés avec des boîtes opposition et
aux couleurs différentes pour s'assurer
que ça n'avait pas d' influence sur le
choix du poisson bon c'est quoi le lien
avec le sentiment amoureux
on va y venir un peu de patience toute
cette préparation donne aux chercheurs
un moyen de tester l'optimisme des
poissons
les chercheurs mettent alors les
poissons face à une situation ambiguë il
dépose au centre de l'aquarium une boîte
au couvercle gris cette botte est donc
un intermédiaire entre les boîtes
contenant des friandises et les boîtes
vides
le poisson peut donc l'interpréter soit
de manière optimiste est allé l'ouvrir
dans l'espoir d'y trouver une friandise
soit de manière pessimiste et l'ignorer
pensons qu'elle n'en contient pas plus
le poisson est optimiste plus rapidement
il ira ouvrir la boîte ce type de tests
cognitifs a déjà été utilisé pour tester
le bien-être des animaux d'élevage comme
les moutons les vaches ben oui ça va
bien l'idée de la chercheuse a été
d'adapter ce test pour mesurer
l'attachement émotionnel aux partenaires
chez les cycliques parce qu'il se trouve
que ces petits poissons tropicaux
forment des couples stables qui
s'occupent à parts égales de défendre le
nid est d'élever les alevins pendant
toute la phase d'apprentissage les
cichlidés sont placés dans des aquariums
par groupe de trois individus de même
sexe des femelles dans cette expérience
un premier test d'optimisme est réalisé
sur la femelle au centre puis on
remplace deux femelles par deux mâles
les trois individus fricote un peu et un
deuxième test d'optimisme est réalisé
sur la femelle la femelle choisi son
partenaire pour la reproduction
puis un des deux mâles lui est retiré et
c soit le mal préféré par la femelle
soit l'autre et enfin un troisième test
d'optimisme et réalise ce que les
chercheurs montre c'est que lorsque la
femelle et séparer temporairement du mal
qu'elle a choisi elle ne s'intéresse
plus à la boîte au couvercle gris son
temps de réponse est long très long
voire elle ne peut pas l'ouvrir
alors que pour les femelles à qui on
enlève le mâle non préféré le temps de
réponse ne change pas cette étude montre
qu'en l'absence de leurs partenaires les
poissons interprète de manière
pessimiste
les signaux ambiguë donc l'état
émotionnel des poissons est affecté par
l'absence du partenaire or un tel
attachement est un des critères de
l'amour romantique notre espèce ne
saurait peut-être pas la seule à avoir
des chagrins d'amour voilà rassurez-vous
la séparation ne dure que quelques
heures et après leur contribution les
poissons partent ensemble en retraite
dans un grand aquarium à beauval à la
porte dorée ou dans les ardennes où ils
pourront couler des jours heureux et à
quoi vous avez vraiment pensé à ce
moment là est ce que c'était un point
dispute de discorde avec votre mère
merci de continuer à nous suivre
n'hésitez pas à partager cet épisode à
mettre un petit pouce bleus est
évidemment abonnez vous